To do this, we need to add a method to our book class. We're going to want to
use the substring method to print out just the text from the beginning to the
first period. So, the first index we should put in is zero because that's the
first index of the character in the book, and then we need to find the end of
the first sentence. We can do this using the indexOf method that we used before
to look for Mad hatter. And now the key here is that substring for the second
argument, wants to take the character after the last character to print. So, if
the last character we want to print is the period and that's our endOfSentence,
we want to give substring endOfSentence plus one. Now in our tester, we'll
want to add another line where we test out our new method and compare it to the
expected value, which is a little long. So, we'll need to split it across a few
different lines. And see how this worked. So, the actual is exactly what we
expected and the expected is missing some line breaks and goes to the side for
a long time. But other than that, it looks like this is basically doing what we
wanted.